- I was born in Bangladesh,
I grew up in U.S.
I have lived in Chicago,
New York, Los Angeles.
I've been coming to Dubai for a while
to see the culture of Middle East.
I like the diversity in
Dubai. It's a melting pot.
And if I can do something astronomic
that is new and exciting
here, it's fulfilling.
(techno rock music)
My names is Mohammad Islam. I am a cook.
Now I live in Dubai. I was trained
in classic French cuisine.
I love French food.
That's my passion.
It is very easy to live
here, and I really like
the local people. They
are extremely humble.
Dubai kind of drew me back here
due to the growth of the country.
Plus, I like the diversity because we have
somewhere around 200 nationalities here.
It's very hard to find
anywhere in the world.
Atelier M is a creation between
the food and the design.
So we use classic techniques
to create modern cuisine.
I have at least eight different
nationalities in the kitchen,
so when we sit down and brainstorm
putting together the culture,
diversity, we come up
with things that I would
never ever think about.
And when you see food that's coming out
beautifully from the kitchen,
it's a great feeling; the synergy,
all the chefs working
together, it's like a family.
One good thing in Dubai that you can get
everything from East as well as West.
So I have Japan very close to me.
I have Australia is not too
far, then I have entire Europe.
For every chef I think
the produce, locally,
it's very, very important.
And I think that's what gives
you the colors of our plate.
I think my vision was right.
Today Dubai is one of the
top food cities you can say.
Internationally recognized chefs are
in Dubai creating modern cuisine.
There's plenty of great
restaurants all around Dubai,
which compete with the
rest of the world today.
Why do I love food?
I think food is everything.
Food is entangled with culture.
Culture is society, and
society is all of us.